So Robyn was the only woman working on this men's magazine, which, OK, is weird to start with. This magazine, you should picture Maxim or FHM , but not as classy. They would get a medium famous TV star, like Alyssa Milano, out into the desert and convince her to take off her top for a photo shoot, that kind of thing.
罗宾是那家男性杂志社唯一的女员工，这从一开始就挺奇怪的。这家杂志社，你可以把它想象成《Maxim》或《FHM》，但没那么高级。他们会把像艾丽莎·米兰诺（Alyssa Milano）这样小有名气的电视明星带到沙漠里，说服她在拍摄时脱掉上衣，就是那种风格。
So, Robyn's working there, and she's 23, just out of college. And she had started as the intern. She would write little music reviews. And then her bosses asked her to do a much more substantial story than she'd ever done, about a Japanese pop star name Seiko.
当时罗宾在那里工作，23岁，刚大学毕业。她最初是作为实习生入职的，写一些短小的音乐评论。后来老板让她做一篇比以往都重要的报道，主角是一位名叫圣子（Seiko）的日本流行歌星。
They came to me, and this was a possible cover. I'm sure my jaw just dropped. And she's coming in tomorrow, she is the Japanese Madonna. You need to go to the photo shoot, she's going to get completely naked. This is the first time that this woman has ever done anything scandalous. And you get to be the one to break this story, of her coming to America.
他们找到我，这可能是个封面故事。我敢肯定当时我的下巴都惊掉了。她明天就要来了，她是日本的麦当娜。你需要去拍摄现场，她会全裸出镜。这是她第一次做这么出格的事。而你将是那个独家报道她来到美国的人。
And how'd that go?
那次采访怎么样？
Um, not well. I hadn't had a lot of experience with high-level celebrities. And she had eight people come to the interview with us. She also had figured out a way of doing this interview style that's very mirroring, where she would repeat back to me what I had asked.
嗯，不太顺利。我没什么应对大牌明星的经验。她带了八个人来参加采访。她还想出了一种非常“镜像式”的采访方式，就是我问她什么，她就重复什么。
Like what? Give me an example.
比如什么？举个例子。
So, "What kind of clothes do you like to wear when you're performing?" "What kinds of clothes would you like to wear?" And I'd be like, "Well, I'm not sure because I'm not performing. But, if I were, I'd probably want to wear chaps, a small cowboy hat." I didn't know how to react, you know? When I was asking her about her romantic life, she would do that same style.
比如，“你演出时喜欢穿什么样的衣服？”“你喜欢穿什么样的衣服？”我就说，“呃，我不确定，因为我不演出。但如果我演出的话，我大概会穿皮裤，戴个小牛仔帽。”我不知道该怎么反应，你知道吗？当我问她感情生活时，她也用同样的风格。
And I think it really worked. It did unsettle me. I'd say, "Are you involved with anyone? What do you love about men?" And she'd be like, "What do you love about men?"
我觉得这招确实管用。这让我很不安。我会说，“你有交往对象吗？你喜欢男人的什么特质？”她就会说，“你喜欢男人的什么特质？”
And I left the interview pretty close to being in tears. So I went home, with a very brief interview, where essentially I had more of myself on tape than I had of her. And I called back to office, and I said, there's just nothing here. On every level, there's nothing here. And they said, well, make it work. It's a 2,000 word piece now. It's a feature. It's our main feature on the feature wall. Go home, and take your notes, and write what you can with it.
采访结束时，我快要哭了。我带着一段非常简短的采访回了家，录音带里基本上是我说的话比她多。我给办公室回电话说，这篇稿子完全没法写。不管从哪个角度看，都没内容。他们说，想办法搞定。这现在是一篇2000字的文章，是专题，是我们专题墙上的主打文章。回家整理笔记，尽量写吧。
So she didn't know what to do. And then she started thinking, OK, how would all the guys in the office write this story? The  magazine she worked for, they did that men's magazine thing where the writer basically just drools over the girl in the story, and how hot that girl is. And Robyn thought, OK, fill enough paragraphs with that and the fact that she had no decent quotes from Seiko wouldn't even matter.
她不知道该怎么办。后来她开始想，办公室里的那些男人会怎么写这篇稿子？她供职的那本杂志，走的就是那种路子：作者基本上就是对着故事里的女孩流口水，夸她有多性感。罗宾想，多写点这种段落，至于她从圣子那里没挖到什么有价值的语录，也就无关紧要了。
And I decided, my name sort of sounds like a boy anyway. I'm just going to write it as if I'm a man who thinks she's the most attractive woman that's ever walked the earth, which is what I did.
我决定，反正我的名字听起来像个男生。我就写得好像我是一个男人，觉得她是这世界上最迷人的女性，于是我就这么做了。
OK. And so we have the article here. Can  I just ask you to read-- here's the article.
好的。我们现在有这篇文章了。能请你读一下吗？这是文章。
OK.
好的。
Can I ask you to just read the first paragraph or two?
能请你读一下第一两段吗？
"The prospect of seeing a beautiful woman's bare skin keeps me sane as I sit in traffic, en route to the photo session for Seiko, the reigning Japanese pop queen. Hot flashes of the Asian teen queen under an erotic spell of the camera blazes me a path through LA, bumper to bumper, and I arrive eager, mentally aroused, and a half an hour late. The nude has been shot.
“在前往日本流行天后圣子拍摄现场的路上，被堵在车流中时，想到能看到一位美女的裸体，让我保持了理智。这位亚裔甜心在相机下呈现的性感魔力，让我在洛杉矶拥挤的车流中感受到阵阵热浪，我怀着渴望和激动的心情迟到了半小时。裸照已经拍完了。”
Proof of the event is handed to me in Polaroid form. There I get my first glimpse of Seiko, as she posed a mere 30 minutes prior wearing only a good girl smile and a fan splayed over her privates. And immediately, I'm consumed with the need to see in person what looks so tempting on film."
“现场的证据以宝丽来照片的形式交到我手中。我在上面第一次瞥见了圣子，她在30分钟前摆拍，只带着纯真的微笑，用一把扇子遮住了私处。瞬间，我被一种强烈的渴望所吞噬，想要亲眼目睹这在胶片上看起来如此诱人的身体。”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yep. Yep, yep, yep.
对。对对对。
Did the men who you work with, did they like this?
和你一起工作的男同事们，他们喜欢这篇文章吗？
They thought it was like, wow, look at her. How cool that our little girl's, you know--
他们觉得，哇，看看她。真酷，我们的小姑娘——
Our little 's growing up.
我们的小姑娘长大了。
Our little girl's growing up to be a misogynist. Were thrilled.
我们的小姑娘长大成了一个厌女症患者。他们兴奋极了。
So after a while, the magazine hits the newsstands. And when Robyn gets to work the next day, her phone is already ringing. It's Seiko's publicist.
过了一段时间，杂志上市了。第二天罗宾去上班时，电话已经响个不停。是圣子的公关打来的。
I thought she was calling me because I had written an article that she found offensive. But I found out it was really she was upset because this woman had gotten naked on the set of our photo shoot, and she was going to have to try to control this so it basically doesn't cause this huge scandal in Japan.
我以为她是打电话来投诉我写的文章冒犯了她。但我发现她其实是因为这个女人在我们的拍摄现场脱了衣服而感到心烦，她得设法控制局面，以免在日本引起巨大的丑闻。
Oh, because she's supposed to be a wholesome girl. That's her image, wholesome girl.
噢，因为她被塑造成纯情少女的形象，那才是她的卖点，纯情少女。
Yes. So this is the first time she's ever really shown skin or anything like that. So I'm waiting in the office, prepared to deal with camera crews that want to talk about her nudity. And I remember I came up-- there might be have even been more than one TV crew waiting in the reception area. And when I came out, and I was a woman, they were completely freaked out.
是的。这是她第一次真正意义上展露肌肤。我在办公室里等着应对那些想报道她裸体事件的电视摄制组。我记得当时接待区甚至可能有不止一个电视组在等我。当我出来时，他们发现我是一个女人，整个人都惊呆了。
Now, the reason why they freaked out-- as best as Robyn was able to piece together later-- the reason why was that when Seiko came to the United States to try to establish herself, not just as a Japanese pop star, but as an American pop star, this rumor started circulating in Japan that Seiko was leaving her husband behind, for some American. And so the press, the Japanese press, were trying to figure out, is there an American? Who was this American?
他们之所以震惊——根据罗宾后来拼凑出的信息——是因为当圣子来到美国试图不仅作为日本流行歌星，更作为美国流行歌星立足时，日本开始流传一种传言，说圣子是为了某个美国人而抛弃了丈夫。所以日本媒体试图弄清楚，那个美国人是谁？
So when they got this article, they were like, well, this person certainly seems obsessed with her, and very sexually hot for her. Maybe Mr. Robyn Forest is her current lover. So when Mr. Robyn Forest came out and Mr. Robyn Forest is a college-aged girl, they were really freaked out.
所以当他们看到这篇文章，他们想，这个人看起来对她非常着迷，性趣盎然。也许“罗宾·福雷斯特先生”就是她的现任情人。所以当罗宾·福雷斯特先生走出来，发现他是个大学年纪的女孩时，他们真的吓坏了。
Now Seiko has left her husband for this college-age girl, who's obsessed with her.
现在变成了圣子为了这个对她着迷的大学生女孩抛弃了丈夫。
Who looks just like an LA surfer girl. And that just sent them into a tizzy.
而且看起来就像个洛杉矶的冲浪女孩。这让他们彻底抓狂了。
Like the story has gotten so much better than they ever dreamed.
故事变得比他们想象中精彩多了。
Right, right, right.
对，没错。
So Robyn sits down for this first interview, and she has no idea about any of this at the time, right? She thinks that they are only there to talk about the nudity. And she tries to do right by Seiko. She says what a nice girl Seiko is, how she hopes Seiko's album does great in the United States. And that was that.
罗宾参加第一次采访时，对这些一无所知，对吧？她以为他们只是为了谈裸照的事。她试图维护圣子。她说圣子是个好女孩，希望她的专辑在美国大卖。事情就到此为止。
So that first interview, I remember I just thought, well, I really set the record straight there. You know? And I thought that would be the end of the TV crews coming.
所以第一次采访，我记得我当时想，好吧，我已经把事实澄清了。你知道吗？我以为这就结束了，不会再有电视组来了。
So then, the second day, about three or four came. So I did another interview with one of them. I thought, well, maybe this will make them leave. And in that interview, that was the first time anyone said, "Are you attracted to her?" And I'm on camera. I was like, oh wait, you think that I-- I was like, "Oh no, no, no, no. I'm not a lesbian."
结果第二天，来了三四家。我采访了其中一家，想着这可能会让他们离开。在那个采访里，有人第一次问：“你被她吸引了吗？”我当时对着镜头，我想，等等，你以为我……我说：“噢不不不，我不是同性恋。”
And did you say you didn't find her sexy? Because you have a whole article here saying you did.
那你有没有说你不觉得她性感？因为你整篇文章都在说你觉得她很性感。
I said, you know, I can recognize that she's attractive as a woman. But no. I'm not attracted to her. And then they would just try to slip in a quick question like, "Did you touch her breast?" And I would be like, "Um, no." And then they'd just move on, really clever. And then they'd be like, "What are your hobbies, Robyn?"
我说，作为女性，我可以承认她很有吸引力。但我没有被她吸引。然后他们就会试图插进一些小问题，比如“你摸她的胸了吗？”我就说，“呃，没有。”然后他们就继续问别的，真聪明。接着他们会问，“罗宾，你有什么爱好？”
They were trying to throw me off. So that third interview, I was starting to get annoyed. And as the interviews got more and more-- I probably did about 20-- they would just get right to the point. "Did you sleep with her? What parts of her body did you see naked? Did you touch her breast? Are you still talking to her?" And then they just didn't even try to be polite.
他们试图让我分心。到第三次采访时，我开始感到恼火了。随着采访越来越多——我大概做了20次——他们开始直截了当。“你跟她上床了吗？你看到她裸体部位了？你摸她胸了吗？你还在跟她联系吗？”他们甚至懒得装礼貌了。
And I was getting hate mail from fans.
我还收到了粉丝寄来的恐吓信。
From her fans?
从她的粉丝那里？
Yeah. And people really just were never convinced that I wasn't the person that was having an affair with her.
是的。人们始终不相信我不是那个和她有私情的人。
Mainly, she just wished that her bosses had killed the story like she asked, back when the original interview went so badly.
总之，她只是希望老板在当初第一次采访搞砸时，能把这篇稿子给毙掉。
I was like, "I told you guys that we shouldn't try to make this into a story. And now look. I'm a lesbian in Japan."
我当时说：“我告诉过你们，我们不应该尝试把它写成专题。现在好了，我在日本成了同性恋。”
And all of this had consequences in America, too. See, before all this, among the very few articles Robyn had ever written, she'd done another story that had made publicists angry with her.
所有这些在美国也带来了后果。要知道，在此之前，罗宾写过的极少数文章中，她曾写过另一篇得罪了公关的文章。
People that are the handlers of celebrities, when they found out about all of this-- the publicists in LA definitely let each other know when things are going wrong. And there was, to some degree, I feel like, a bit of a black ball going on. My reputation was that of being a wild card. Maybe not to trusted with bigger celebrities. So I recognized that this is probably the end for me. It was pretty much done.
那些负责明星的公关们，当他们发现这一切后——洛杉矶的公关们肯定会互相通气。在某种程度上，我觉得我被封杀了。我的名声成了一个“不确定因素”。也许不能再委以重任，去报道更大牌的明星。所以我意识到，我的职业生涯大概到此为止了。基本上全完了。
So wait, so your entire career in journalism, you basically wrote two stories. You ruined your own reputation.
等等，也就是说你整个新闻职业生涯，就写了两篇报道。你就毁了自己的名声。
Yes. I did. And that was it.
是的。我做到了。就这样。
That was it. You don't get to choose what makes your reputation. One dumb mistake can do it.
就这样了。你无法选择是什么造就了你的名声。一个愚蠢的错误就足够了。
Well from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, My Reputation. Stories of people finding themselves at the mercy of what other people think of them. And very much not agreeing with what other people think of them.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们节目的主题是“我的名声”。讲述那些发现自己受制于他人评价的人们的故事。而且他们非常不同意他人的那种评价。
Act one of our show, Not Everybody Loves Raymond. It that act, we have the story of a politician who goes through the kind of scandal that destroys a person's reputation. But he's the unusual politician in that he is willing to talk about it all, with a reporter, in a way you never hear. Act two, The Hole Truth. A man asks his closest friends, on tape, what they really think of him. And he is surprised at what they say. And not in a good way. Stay with us.
第一幕，不是每个人都爱雷蒙德。在这一幕中，我们将讲述一位政客经历了一场足以毁掉个人名声的丑闻。但他是个罕见的愿意与记者畅谈这一切的政客。第二幕，“真相大白”。一个男人在录音机前问他最亲近的朋友们对他的真实看法。结果让他感到意外，而且不是好消息。请继续收听。
Act one, Not Everybody Love Raymond. This story begins right after a political stampede in New Hampshire. Last year, Democrats won majorities in the State Senate, in the House, they toppled both incumbent Republicans in congress to take the state's two house seats in Washington. They already had a Democratic governor, but now they also took local boards and city councils.
第一幕，不是每个人都爱雷蒙德。故事开始于新罕布什尔州一场政治风暴之后。去年，民主党赢得了州参议院和众议院的多数席位，击败了国会的两名现任共和党人，夺取了该州在华盛顿的两个众议院席位。他们本来就有民主党州长，现在还拿下了地方委员会和市议会。
The day after the election, Republicans called it a tsunami. Keep in mind, this is New Hampshire, which is usually dominated by Republicans. A kind of Libertarian "Live free or die" sort of Republican. The last time Democrats had the House and the Senate and the governor's mansion in New Hampshire? 1874. The last time they had all that, and the two representatives in DC was in the 1850s.
选举后的第二天，共和党人称之为“海啸”。请记住，这可是新罕布什尔州，通常由共和党主导。那是一种自由意志主义的、推崇“不自由毋宁死”的共和党。上次民主党同时掌握新罕布什尔州的众议院、参议院和州长官邸是什么时候？1874年。而上次他们同时掌握这些，还拥有两位国会众议员，是在1850年代。
In a sense, the politics of New Hampshire is, in a way, small town politics. State Representative is a part-time job. It only pays $100 a year. Political news happens on a half dozen public cable access shows that not many people watch. But it's also sort of big politics, because New Hampshire, of course, has the first presidential primary in the country. And New Hampshire politicians and political operatives hang out for months with the presidential hopefuls.
从某种意义上说，新罕布什尔州的政治是小镇政治。州代表是份兼职，年薪只有100美元。政治新闻发生在半打公共有线电视节目上，没多少人看。但它同时也是大政治，因为新罕布什尔州当然是全国第一个进行总统初选的地方。该州的政治人物和运作人员几个月来都与总统候选人混在一起。
OK. So that is the setting for this story Sarah Koenig, tells what happened.
好的。这就是故事的背景，莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）将讲述发生的事情。
The day after election day was suddenly a very, very good time to be a Democrat in New Hampshire. And a good time to be Ray Buckley, too. Buckley was one of the main strategists behind the landslide. Here's how he began his weekly political talk show on cable access TV the next morning.
选举日后的第二天，对新罕布什尔州的民主党人来说，突然成了一个非常好的日子。对雷·巴克利（Ray Buckley）来说也是。巴克利是这场压倒性胜利背后的主要策略家之一。这是他第二天早上在有线电视公共频道上开始他每周政治脱口秀时的样子。
[MUSIC - "WE ARE THE  CHAMPIONS" BY QUEEN]
[皇后乐队的《我们是冠军》]
The takeover caused statewide euphoria among Democrats, but you'd be hard-pressed to find anyone happier about it than Buckley. He'd been waiting for this day nearly his entire life.
这次接管让全州的民主党人欢欣鼓舞，但你很难找到比巴克利更高兴的人了。他几乎毕生都在等待这一天。
Is New Hampshire going to become a permanent democratic state? That makes every phone call, every envelope that I've stuffed, every sign that I've put up, every single bit of that over the last 40 years, absolutely worth it. Because I feel this is what this has all been for.
新罕布什尔州会成为一个永久的民主党州吗？这使得我过去40年里打的每一个电话，塞的每一个信封，挂的每一块标语，所有这一切都绝对值得。因为我觉得这就是这一切的目的所在。
Buckley is a tall, blond, round-faced guy who doesn't like the outdoors and has the figure to prove it. He's either called an operative or a hack, depending on your point of view. Whatever he does, he's good at it. And by now he should be. He says he's been obsessed by politics since third grade. By the time he was 14, he made his mother volunteer to run his town's Democratic committee, a job he was actually already doing, but was too young to have officially. Because he was 14.
巴克利是个高个子、金发、圆脸的家伙，不喜欢户外运动，他的身材就是证明。根据你的看法，他被称为“运作人员”或“政客黑客”。无论他做什么，他都很擅长。到现在他也该擅长了。他说他从三年级起就沉迷于政治。14岁时，他就让他母亲去当小镇民主党委员会的志愿者，这份工作其实他已经在做了，但因为他才14岁，还没法正式担任。
And since then, he's been deep in political campaigns all the time. Either running himself-- he was a state rep for 18 years-- or getting other people elected. He knows the stats on hundreds of Democrats around the state. I found this out at a fundraiser when I casually asked him the name of the woman we'd just been talking to.
从那时起，他就一直深入参与政治竞选。要么是自己参选——他当了18年的州代表——要么是帮别人竞选。他了解州内数百名民主党人的数据。我在一次筹款活动上偶然问他刚刚谈话的那位女士的名字时，就发现了这一点。
Her first name is Ellie, that woman?
那女士的名字是艾莉（Ellie），对吧？
Ellie Carpenito.
艾莉·卡佩尼托（Ellie Carpenito）。
艾莉·卡佩尼托。
Yep. From Salem. 15 Scully Square, 03079.
没错。来自塞勒姆。斯库利广场15号，邮编03079。
And how do you know that?
你是怎么知道的？
I remember most people's address and phone numbers and emails. That's--
大部分人的地址和电话号码、邮箱我都记得。这就是——
You do?
你真的记得？
Some of these people I've been mailing-- I've either hand addressed or put labels for 20, 30 years on an envelope. You know?
其中一些人我已经寄了20、30年的信了——要么是手写地址，要么是贴标签。你知道吗？
What's her address?
那她的地址呢？
Maggie Lozano? 417 Walnut Street, Manchester, New Hampshire.
玛吉·洛萨诺（Maggie Lozano）？曼彻斯特核桃街417号，新罕布什尔州。
He's probably been to a lot of their houses, too. New Hampshire is tiny, about a million people. So everybody knows everybody for years back. Especially, it seems, in the political world. And for Buckley, this decades-long attention to who's who paid off in November's victories.
他可能也去过他们很多人家里。新罕布什尔州很小，大约一百万人。所以每个人多年来都互相认识。尤其是在政治圈里。对于巴克利来说，这种几十年来对“谁是谁”的关注，在十一月的胜利中得到了回报。
A few years ago, the Senate Democrats asked him to run their Political Action Committee. He said yes, but only if they'd sign on to what a lot of people thought was a pipe dream. To not only keep the eight seats they had, but to take a majority of the Senate. He studied 20 years' worth of financial records. He invented a new fundraising strategy. And he forced safe candidates, the incumbents, to help the new candidates.
几年前，参议院民主党人让他负责他们的政治行动委员会。他答应了，但前提是他们得同意一个被很多人认为是白日梦的目标：不仅保住现有的八个席位，还要赢得参议院多数席位。他研究了20年的财务记录，发明了新的筹款策略，并强迫安全选区的候选人去帮助新候选人。
It worked. They took the Senate and helped Democrats all the way down the ticket. Now Buckley wanted to be chairman of the party. He wanted to be the guy to make sure New Hampshire stayed democratic for good.
成功了。他们拿下了参议院，并帮助民主党在整个选票上获胜。现在巴克利想竞选党主席。他想成为确保新罕布什尔州永远保持民主党阵营的那个人。
It's an elected position and it only took two weeks for Buckley to get more than a 140 of the 196 committee members to promise they'd vote for him, including all the state's most influential Democrats.
这是一个选举职位，巴克利只用了两周时间，就获得了196名委员会成员中超过140人的投票承诺，包括州内最有影响力的民主党人。
But three months before the vote, Buckley was accused of one of the worst things a person can be accused of. Something so ugly and dark that almost no one accused of it ever really shakes it, guilty or not. It threatened to ruin not just his career, but his life.
但在投票前三个月，巴克利被指控犯下了一个人可能被指控的最糟糕的事情之一。这件事如此丑陋和黑暗，以至于几乎没有被指控者能真正摆脱它，无论是否有罪。这不仅威胁到他的职业生涯，甚至威胁到他的生命。
We've all seen this story from a distance. The politician accused, the public outcry, embattled press conferences, TV crews tailing a haunted official on his way to a waiting car. And that's all we get. We rarely get to hear what happens offstage. For Ray Buckley, the hardest thing was getting his mind around what the accusation meant. That his dream job, the job he'd already locked up, had suddenly vanished.
我们都从远处见过这样的故事。被指控的政客，公众的抗议，陷入困境的新闻发布会，电视组尾随一个神情落魄的官员前往等待的汽车。这就是我们所知道的全部。我们很少能听到幕后发生了什么。对雷·巴克利来说，最困难的是弄清楚这一指控意味着什么。他那已经胜券在握的梦想工作，竟然就这样瞬间消失了。
And that was part of the horror during the ordeal. To suddenly be benched, at a time that is going to be a watershed time for our party, was just-- it's not just the public humiliation, it's not just all of the other stuff of having all these enormous legal bills. It was, I'd just spent 40 years working towards this, and it's gone.
这就是整个磨难中最恐怖的一部分。在我们要党内迎来分水岭的时候，突然被排挤出局，不仅是公众的羞辱，不仅仅是背负着巨大的法律费用。而是我花了40年时间才达到这一步，而它就这样没了。
The whole thing started with another politician. A guy named Steve Vaillancourt. Vaillancourt is a Republican state representative from Manchester. An eccentric, and a viper when provoked. And he's often provoked.
整件事始于另一位政客。一个叫史蒂夫·瓦兰考特（Steve Vaillancourt）的家伙。瓦兰考特是曼彻斯特的共和党州代表。一个古怪的人，被激怒时就像毒蛇一样。他经常被激怒。
I once wrote a profile of him for the Concord Monitor newspaper, in which a colleague affectionately compared him to nuclear waste. He sometimes harmed the very causes he fought for, legalized gambling, legalized marijuana, abolishing the death penalty. He's in perpetual motion and he's also obsessive. He once wrote a book of 5,000 trivia questions about the OJ Simpson trial.
我曾经为《康科德箴言报》写过一篇他的侧写，一位同事深情地把他比作核废料。他有时会伤害他所支持的事业，比如合法化赌博、合法化大麻、废除死刑。他永远处于运动中，而且有强迫症。他曾经写过一本关于辛普森案的5000个琐事问答的书。
To give you some sense of his frantic style, he's got his own public access TV show called More Politically Alert . And the unedited rawness of it is kind of remarkable.
为了让你了解他狂热的风格，他有自己的公共频道节目《更加政治警觉》（More Politically Alert）。那种未经剪辑的原始感真是非同寻常。
Here he's talking about the committee he has just been assigned to in the Legislature, Environment and Agriculture. What he wanted was the Finance Committee, and he doesn't disguise that.
在这里，他谈论的是他刚被分配到的立法委员会：环境与农业。他想要的是财政委员会，他毫不掩饰这一点。
We have the introduction of Steve Taylor, the Department of Agriculture chairman came in. We make almost a billion dollars a year out of agriculture in this state, and about half of that comes from flowers and garden supplies and things like that. It's going to be a fun year on the Agriculture Committee, not that I deserve to be on Finance, although Ben Baroody, and Tom Fahey, junior leader column, said that I was much better suited for finance than him.
我们介绍了农业部主席史蒂夫·泰勒。我们州每年通过农业赚取近10亿美元，其中约一半来自花卉和园艺用品等。农业委员会将是很有趣的一年，并不是说我该去财政委员会，尽管本·巴鲁迪（Ben Baroody）和汤姆·费希（Tom Fahey）说我比他更适合财政。
And most other people say I'm intelligent. All the media this week has been saying, you're one of the most intelligent people around. Well I've never claimed to be intelligent, or unintelligent, I've just claimed to be what I am, a meat eater. [LAUGHTER] Oh my god.
大多数人都说我很聪明。这周所有的媒体都说，你是周围最聪明的人之一。嗯，我从未声称自己聪明或不聪明，我只是声称我是什么样的人，一个食肉者。[笑声] 天哪。
It's all like this. A dazzling stream of consciousness that's like an unfiltered glimpse into his brain, and it's also completely entertaining. Vaillancourt is theatrical, but he's also smart, so his colleagues don't tune him out completely. And it was on his show, in early January, that he dropped this little bomb about the chairman's race.
全是这样的。一连串令人眼花缭乱的意识流，就像直接窥视他的大脑，而且也完全具有娱乐性。瓦兰考特很有表演欲，但他也很聪明，所以他的同事们不会完全无视他。就在一月初，他在节目中投下了一枚关于党主席竞选的炸弹。
That front runner, Ray Buckley, will not win as the Democratic party chairman in balloting later in January. You heard it here first, a shoe will drop.
领先者雷·巴克利，将不会在一月后期的投票中赢得民主党主席的席位。你在这里先听到了，一只鞋子会掉下来。
Later in the show, he cues a swirly background, and repeats this forecast about Buckley, in the looser Vaillancourt style.
节目后期，他安排了一个旋转的背景，并用瓦兰考特更随意的风格重复了这一预测。
Whoa, whoa, whoa. I'm getting dizzy. Watch out, or Ray Buckley will say I'm drooling. Hey Ray-bo, how you doing? You are not going to be Chairman of the Democratic party, we predict.
哇，哇，哇。我头晕了。小心点，否则雷·巴克利会说我在流口水。嘿，雷波，你怎么样？我们预测你不会成为民主党主席。
Vaillancourt knew a shoe would drop in the chairman's race, because he had already dropped it. He had written a letter to governor John Lynch. "Raymond Buckley," he wrote, "has a long history with kiddie pornography. I know for a fact that Mr. Buckley used to smuggle kiddie porn from Amsterdam and Denmark into the United States inside Newsweek and other magazines. You could not enter his room without stepping over kiddie porn, strewn on the floor," the letter said.
瓦兰考特知道党主席竞选中会有“鞋子掉下来”，因为他自己已经扔出去了。他给州长约翰·林奇（John Lynch）写了一封信。“雷蒙德·巴克利，”他写道，“有漫长的儿童色情历史。我确信巴克利先生曾把儿童色情内容藏在《新闻周刊》和其他杂志里带进美国。你如果不跨过地板上散乱的儿童色情内容，就进不了他的房间，”信中说。
Someone leaked the letter to the TV news and, once it got out, it was huge.
有人把这封信泄露给了电视新闻，一旦泄露，事情就闹大了。
Sources tell News 9 , a fellow politician and former friend of Buckley's--
消息来源告诉第9频道新闻，一位同僚政客和巴克利的前朋友——
Well, Jen and Tom, this is the letter. It's dated December 26, it's a one-pager, written by state representative Steve Vaillancourt.
嗯，简和汤姆，这就是这封信。日期是12月26日，一页纸，由州代表史蒂夫·瓦兰考特撰写。
It accuses Buckley of being attracted to boys aged four through nine. It talks about a computer purchased by the Manchester City Democrats in 1998, and allegedly used by Buckley to surf the Internet for child porn.
它指控巴克利被四到九岁的男孩吸引。信中谈到了曼彻斯特市民主党在1998年购买的一台电脑，据称巴克利曾用它浏览儿童色情网站。
Buckley emphatically denies the allegations, but he has not responded to repeated attempts for interviews. The investigation--
巴克利坚决否认这些指控，但他没有回应多次采访请求。调查——
Vaillancourt ended the letter by saying "I can only assume that even a cursory investigation will convince you that Mr. Buckley is not the person Democrats, or New Hampshire, want in a leadership position." The man he sent the letter to, Governor Lynch, has made it a priority to get tougher prison sentences for child predators. And Vaillancourt almost dared him to ignore the letter.
瓦兰考特在信的结尾说：“我只能假设，即便是粗略的调查，也能让你确信巴克利先生不是民主党或新罕布什尔州想要担任领导职务的人。”他写信的对象，林奇州长，一直将严惩虐童犯作为优先事项。瓦兰考特简直是在挑战他不要忽视这封信。
And he hit the most sensitive political issue in the state. New Hampshire's status as the first place to hold presidential primaries every four years. Last summer, Nevada moved its caucus ahead of New Hampshire's primary, and New Hampshire officials have been freaking out ever since. A scandal at the top of the party could give presidential candidates pause. Would they really want to pose for pictures with an accused pervert? And might give other states ammunition for arguing that New Hampshire shouldn't be first anymore.
他击中了该州最敏感的政治问题：新罕布什尔州每四年作为第一个总统初选地的地位。去年夏天，内华达州把党团会议移到了新罕布什尔州初选之前，新罕布什尔州的官员们一直为此抓狂。党内高层的丑闻可能会让总统候选人犹豫。他们真的想和一个被指控的变态合影吗？这可能会给其他州攻击新罕布什尔州不该再排第一的口实。
So Governor Lynch responded as Vaillancourt must have known he would.
所以林奇州长做出了瓦兰考特必然预料到的反应。
There were serious allegations made by a state representative, which is why we immediately forwarded the letter to the Department of Justice, and they are managing the situation now.
有一位州代表提出了严重的指控，这就是为什么我们立即将这封信转发给司法部，他们现在正在处理此事。
And this was the other thing Lynch said.
这也是林奇说的另一件事。
Well, you know, I didn't and I don't believe that while this matter is pending he should be running for state party chair.
嗯，你知道，我不认为在问题待决期间，他应该竞选州党主席。
Vaillancourt began pushing his case in public. He held an interminable press conference. In the first two and a half minutes, he somehow managed to weave together Julius Caesar, Berlin, Germany, the San Diego Chargers and Catherine the Great. But he also had moments of clarity.
瓦兰考特开始公开推动他的案子。他举行了一场冗长的新闻发布会。在头两分半钟里，他竟然把凯撒大帝、柏林、德国、圣地亚哥闪电队和叶卡捷琳娜大帝串联在了一起。但他也有清醒的时刻。
I don't need to be here. So if you ask me, is this going to ruin your career, Representative Vaillancourt, and I've been asked that often. Ruin my career? Ruin a $100 a year job? Ruin my reputation? I say what I feel because I believe somebody has to step forward and tell the truth. I'm not going to come off looking like a good guy no matter what happens, somebody that turns in a friend. But if you believe me, then you've got to believe that at least a dozen, maybe two dozen, maybe more, have known about this for a long time. If you believe me. And as I say, don't believe me if you don't want to, but I do not lie.
我没必要在这。所以如果你问我，这会毁了你的职业生涯吗，瓦兰考特代表，而且我经常被问到这个问题。毁了我的职业生涯？毁了一份年薪100美元的工作？毁了我的名声？我说出我的感受，因为我相信总得有人站出来说真话。无论发生什么，我看起来都不会是个好人，一个出卖朋友的人。但如果你相信我，那你必须相信，至少有十几、二十几，甚至更多的人早就知道了。如果你相信我。就像我说的，不想信就别信，但我从不撒谎。
I do exaggerate, occasionally I do comedy. But I never lie. I do tend to exaggerate. And most of the things I've said I don't have proof about, but I think I have enough information so that if you don't want to believe me, you better think twice about not believing me.
我确实会夸张，偶尔会讲些喜剧，但我从不撒谎。我确实倾向于夸张。大多数我所说的事情我都没有证据，但我认为我有足够的信息，所以如果你不想相信我，你最好三思而后行。
I'm looking, reading a letter that my first response is, boy, to have written this sort of a letter, he's got to really hate you.
我看着读着这封信，我的第一反应是，天哪，写出这种信，他一定非常恨你。
Before it made the TV news, before it made the paper, Ray Buckley had gotten a knock at his office door, and two friends had sat him down in a conference room and showed him the letter.
在电视新闻报道之前，在报纸刊登之前，雷·巴克利办公室的门被敲响，两个朋友把他带进会议室，给他看了这封信。
And then I just, I was kind of thinking of him and saying, I don't think he's thought this through. I don't think he realizes what he just did. And so we went through the letter, step by step, and it was like, there's no truth to any of this. There's nobody that's going to corroborate any of this. How could anyone take this letter seriously?
然后我当时想的是他，说，我不认为他想过后果。我不认为他意识到他刚刚做了什么。所以我们逐行看完了这封信，所有的指控都不是真的。没人会佐证这些。怎么会有人当真呢？
His friends assured him the governor was taking it seriously, and that he'd rescinded his support for Buckley's candidacy. Since he's the most important Democrat in the state, their top elected official, this was a big deal. As was the fact that he publicly called for Buckley to withdraw. But Buckley thought, well, it's such nonsense, it'll blow over.
他的朋友向他保证州长当真了，并撤回了对巴克利竞选的支持。既然他是州内最重要的民主党人，最高民选官员，这事就大了。他公开要求巴克利退选也是。但巴克利想，嗯，这太荒谬了，风头会过去的。
I was thinking, well it's just going to take a couple days, it's going to be over with by the end of the week and it probably might not even ever make the papers.
我当时想，嗯，只要几天时间，到周末就会结束，可能甚至都不会上报纸。
Well, I went out of the meeting and, at this point, it's now after 5:00. I went home.
嗯，我离开会议时，已经是下午5点多了。我回了家。
Are you alone?
你一个人吗？
Yeah. I sorted socks. At that point, I didn't want to upset my family, so I didn't want to call them. I couldn't talk to any of my immediate friends, in case they were going to be called in for questioning. So I had nobody to talk to. So I remembered that I really hadn't organized my sock drawer for a while, and I brought them all in, and dumped them on the couch and I sat there, watching TV and matched socks.
是。我整理了袜子。在那一刻，我不想让家人心烦，所以我不想打电话。我无法与任何亲密朋友交谈，以防他们被叫去问话。所以我没人可说。我记起我已经很久没整理袜子抽屉了，于是我把它们都拿出来，倒在沙发上，一边看电视一边配对袜子。
It sounds calming, but Buckley says his mind was racing. He's the oldest of nine children and he's close with his parents and step-parents. And he was horrified at the idea that they would all be drawn into this somehow. And what was going to happen to his career? And how would he pay for the lawyer? And how should he act right this minute? He started to get a little paranoid.
听起来很冷静，但巴克利说他的大脑飞速运转。他是九个孩子中的老大，与父母和继父母关系亲密。他非常恐惧他们会被卷入其中。他的职业生涯会怎样？他怎么付得起律师费？他现在该怎么做？他开始变得有点偏执。
You know, are the police going to show up at my door tonight? So, don't move anything. I watched one too many TV shows, I guess. I'm thinking they're going to say, oh, if you moved that book, and so there's no dust there. I didn't dare touch anything in my house. I literally didn't even throw out my trash for the first couple weeks. I put it in my basement, so I could say, nothing has left this house. Here's my trash.
你知道，警察今晚会出现在我家门口吗？所以，什么都别动。我想我看了太多的电视节目了。我心想，如果我移动了那本书，就不会有灰尘了。我不敢碰家里的任何东西。前几周我甚至没扔过垃圾。我把垃圾放在地下室，这样我就能说，没有任何东西离开过这所房子。这是我的垃圾。
I didn't clean out my car. Because I was afraid that someone would see me taking something out of my car and throwing it away. And I would be accused of throwing something out. So my car through the whole ordeal, just became increasingly filled with random stuff. There were Christmas gifts that I just hadn't taken out of the car yet.
我没清理车子。因为我怕有人看到我把车里的东西拿出来扔掉。我会被指控销毁证据。所以在整个磨难期间，我的车里装满了各种乱七八糟的东西。有些圣诞礼物我还没从车里拿出来。
Your fear and-- the first night, I look over at the pictures of my 10 nieces and six nephews. It was like, are they going to think that odd that I have my nieces and nephews on my living room wall? Do other uncles have their nieces and nephews? I don't know. Does that imply something ugly?
你的恐惧……第一天晚上，我看着墙上挂的10个侄女和6个侄子的照片。心想，他们会觉得我把他们挂在客厅墙上很奇怪吗？其他叔叔也挂吗？我不知道。这暗示了什么丑事吗？
He couldn't sleep. And for the first time in his life, he lost his appetite. Over the next two months he'd lose 40 pounds. He'd lie awake at 4:00 in the morning and obsess, so he tried sleeping pills, which didn't really help. Of course, he had to tell his parents that soon all their friends were going to see their son accused of kiddie porn in the news. He says this isn't something anyone wishes on their parents. It's like they're being punished, too.
他睡不着觉。生平第一次，他没了胃口。接下来的两个月他瘦了40磅。他每天凌晨4点醒着发愁，所以尝试了安眠药，但没什么用。当然，他很快得告诉父母，他们所有的朋友都会在新闻里看到他们的儿子被指控恋童。他说这不是任何人希望发生在父母身上的事。就像他们也受到了惩罚一样。
His family was still recovering from the death of his 11-year-old niece, who died of cystic fibrosis. He says at least when something like that happens, family friends know how to react.
他的家人还在从11岁的侄女因囊性纤维化去世的伤痛中恢复。他说至少当那种事发生时，家人们知道该怎么反应。
People, they would offer my parents and my siblings or whatever, love and support. People knew how to show that sort of support to a family that's grieving.
人们会给我父母和兄弟姐妹提供爱和支持。人们知道如何对一个悲伤的家庭表现出那种支持。
It's like it's hard, but you know what to say.
就像这很难，但你知道该说什么。
Exactly. Exactly. This is not something that you naturally know whether to bring it up, not to bring it up. It is a whole different conversation of like, oh, isn't this horrible, this is happening to Raymond. And knowing, deep down, that a person is like, oh, this is really-- it just goes down a road that you don't go when you're showing your sympathy towards a grieving family.
没错。确实如此。这不是那种你自然而然知道是否该提起的话题。这是一种完全不同的对话，比如“噢，这太可怕了，雷蒙德竟然发生这种事。”而且内心深处知道，别人会想“噢，这太……”，它会走向那种你向悲伤家庭表达同情时绝对不会触及的方向。
Once the news hit, Buckley figured out pretty quickly that the investigation would take weeks, not days, and he finally did what the governor wanted. He pulled out of the chairman's race. And all this time, of course, he had stuff to do. He was head of the Manchester City Democrats, vice chair the New Hampshire Democratic Party, chairman of the Eastern Region of the DNC, a member of its executive committee. He was vice president the state Chairs Association, and a board member of the National Stonewall Democrats. And he still had a day job, as executive director of the Senate Democratic Caucus. He had to go to work.
一旦新闻爆出，巴克利很快意识到调查会持续几周，而不是几天，他最终做了州长想让他做的事。他退出了主席竞选。与此同时，他当然还有很多工作要做。他是曼彻斯特市民主党负责人，新罕布什尔州民主党副主席，全国民主党东部地区主席，执行委员会成员。他是州主席协会副主席，也是“全国石墙民主党人”董事会成员。他还有一份正式工作，是参议院民主党核心小组执行主任。他得去上班。
And all day long he's talking to people who are reading these headlines. But for Buckley one advantage of doing politics in such a small place, is that everybody knew him. And they also knew Vaillancourt, and they knew the history between them. And most people reacted to the charges with skepticism.
整天他都在和读过这些头条新闻的人交谈。但对巴克利来说，在一个这么小的地方搞政治的一个优势是，大家都认识他。他们也认识瓦兰考特，他们知道他们之间的过往。大多数人对这些指控持怀疑态度。
Even the state's most notoriously conservative newspaper, the Union Leader , said, quote, "This is nothing more than a suspect allegation, and it should be treated as such." The fact that Vaillancourt admitted having no proof made headlines. No political leaders at the state level, Republican or Democrat, stood by Vaillancourt, who told me that many people in the gay community did come to him privately, saying they believed him, even if not many public figures did.
甚至该州最臭名昭著的保守派报纸《联合领袖报》也说，“这不过是一个可疑的指控，应该被当作此类处理。”瓦兰考特承认没有证据成为了头条新闻。没有州级政治领袖，无论是共和党还是民主党，支持瓦兰考特，瓦兰考特告诉我，许多同性恋群体的人确实私下找到他，说他们相信他，即使公开人物很少这样做。
I was vilified, but I expected to be vilified. People that I had talked to, friends of mine in advance, said, don't do this, it's going to be down to your detriment. I decided that to get my conscience clear once and for all, I would put it out there no matter what it cost me.
我被妖魔化了，但我预料到了。我事先和朋友交谈过，他们说，别这样做，这会对你不利。我决定为了彻底清白我的良心，无论付出什么代价，我都要说出来。
Meanwhile, Buckley's friends and allies, it was almost as if they started a campaign to keep Buckley from curling up into a fetal position and never leaving his house. This is Donna Soucy, who works for the Senate Democrats.
与此同时，巴克利的朋友和盟友，简直像是发起了一场运动，防止巴克利蜷缩成一团永远不出家门。这是唐娜·苏西（Donna Soucy），她为参议院民主党工作。
Most importantly in the beginning, I was the one who made him just go to public events, and just reach out.
最重要的是在开始的时候，我是一直逼他去参加公共活动，多接触别人的人。
Kathy Sullivan was chairwoman of the state party at the time.
凯西·沙利文（Kathy Sullivan）是当时州党主席。
A couple of us said to Raymond, you are going to the inauguration. It's important for you to be out there.
我们几个人对雷蒙德说，你一定要去参加就职典礼。让你出现在公众视野很重要。
Judy Reardon, former Chief of Staff for a previous governor.
朱迪·里尔登（Judy Reardon），前州长幕僚长。
You know, be out there. Don't not go to things. He went to the governor's Inaugural Ball the next day after it had broken publicly. And he said, again, they're not going to want me there. And we said, no, you are going to the Inaugural Ball because you have to show people that you're not hiding, you have nothing to be ashamed of, that this is all crap.
你知道，出现在外面。别不去参加活动。在新闻爆出公开的第二天，他就去了州长的就职舞会。他说，他们肯定不想我在那儿。我们说，不，你一定要去，因为你得向人们展示你没有躲藏，你没做什么可耻的事，这一切都是垃圾。
All his friends operated from this notion, that it was all crap. And they were confident about that because this was just the latest skirmish between Vaillancourt and Buckley.
他所有的朋友都基于这是一个垃圾的观点行事。他们很有信心，因为这只是瓦兰考特和巴克利之间的最新冲突。
For the last 10 years or so, Vaillancourt has had it out for Ray Buckley for reasons that only Vaillancourt knows. I've asked and asked, and no one seems to have the answer. Or at least admits they do. There are theories. Unrequited love, chief among them. They're both gay, but both men swear there's never been a romantic or sexual moment between them. And it's convincing when they say that. They make that face you might make when you imagine your parents in bed.
过去十年左右，瓦兰考特一直针对雷·巴克利，原因只有瓦兰考特自己知道。我问了又问，没人知道答案。或者至少没人承认知道。有很多理论，单相思位居榜首。他们都是同性恋，但两人都发誓他们之间从未有过浪漫或性关系。当他们说这些时令人信服。他们会做出那种当你想象父母在床上时可能会做的表情。
Their friends second the denials. Katherine Rogers has known them both for decades. And she makes that same face.
他们的朋友也附和这种否认。凯瑟琳·罗杰斯（Katherine Rogers）几十年来一直认识他们两人。她做了同样的表情。
Was he in love with Raymond Buckley. Like, why--?
他爱雷蒙德·巴克利吗？为什么……？
Oh god, no. And I've seen it in print, you know, maybe there was some relationship. No. There was never anything with the two of them.
噢天哪，不。我在媒体上看到过，也许有过什么关系。不。他们俩之间从来没有任何事。
But Buckley rented a room in Vaillancourt's house for 16 years, and they were close friends. They hung out all the time, and travelled together. They both talk about taking care of each other when one was sick or depressed. Vaillancourt used to be painfully shy, and Kathy Rogers remembers trying to lure him out of his room with M&Ms, ET style.
但巴克利在瓦兰考特家租过16年的房子，他们曾是密友。他们经常混在一起，一起旅行。他们俩谈论在对方生病或抑郁时如何照顾对方。瓦兰考特曾经非常害羞，凯西·罗杰斯记得曾试图用M&M巧克力诱惑他走出房间，就像电影《外星人》那样。
But Buckley encouraged him to run for the House, and he did. Back then, Vaillancourt was a Democrat. And once he was elected, he was quickly promoted to leadership positions because he was talented. But so was Buckley.
但巴克利鼓励他竞选众议院，他也确实做了。那时候，瓦兰考特还是民主党人。一旦当选，他很快就被提升到领导职位，因为他很有才华。但巴克利也是。
He'd become the Democratic Whip, and Vaillancourt was furious.
他成了民主党党鞭，瓦兰考特气坏了。
This is Peter Burling. He was House Democratic Leader back then, and he says Vaillancourt behaved so badly after that, attacking Buckley, attacking him, that he had to demote him.
这是彼得·伯林（Peter Burling）。他那时是众议院民主党领袖，他说瓦兰考特在那之后表现得太糟糕，攻击巴克利，攻击他，以至于不得不把他降职。
You know, on some level, as I look at these episodes over the last 14 years, I cannot help feeling a profound sense of sadness for Mr. Vaillancourt. It is clear that there is a whole level of competitive anxiety, shall we say, that Ray Buckley's success brings out in Mr. Vaillancourt.
你知道，在某种层面上，当我回顾过去14年里的这些插曲时，我不禁对瓦兰考特先生感到深深的悲哀。很明显，雷·巴克利的成功给瓦兰考特带来了整整一个层面的竞争焦虑。
After that demotion, Vaillancourt started to break with the party. Around that same time, he kicked Buckley out of his house, and they went to court over claims of unpaid rent. It wasn't long before Vaillancourt became a Republican.
在那次降职后，瓦兰考特开始与党派分道扬镳。大约在同一时间，他把巴克利赶出了他的房子，他们因为拖欠房租的诉求闹上了法庭。没过多久，瓦兰考特就变成了共和党人。
And all this stuff was very public. Not only because of the smallness of the place, because of public access TV in Manchester. Politics in that city, in particular, as Peter Burling said to me, is of the whack and slash variety. This plays out in about half a dozen political TV shows, which can get mean.
所有这些事情都非常公开。不仅仅是因为地方小，还因为曼彻斯特的公共有线电视。彼得·伯林对我说，那个城市的政治特别是“棍棒与砍刀”风格的。这一切发生在半打政治电视节目上，有时会变得很卑劣。
And Buckley is no innocent here. He can be refined and diplomatic, attending small private gatherings with Barack Obama or John Edwards, but he also gets nasty. That's his job as a party operative. He's like James Carville. On his show, In the Know , he's called other politicians half-witted and freakish, suggested they were mildly retarded, or plastered. And just a few months before Vaillancourt sent his letter to the governor, Buckley went after him.
巴克利在这里也不是无辜的。他可以文雅、外交，参加奥巴马或约翰·爱德华兹的小型私人聚会，但他也会变得下流。这是他作为党务人员的工作。他就像詹姆斯·卡维尔（James Carville）。在他的节目《知情者》（In the Know）中，他曾称其他政客为“低能”和“怪胎”，暗示他们智障或喝醉了。就在瓦兰考特给州长写信的几个月前，巴克利还攻击过他。
Do you want this guy representing you? Do you want your family's reputation stained by having this guy, who absolutely gets unhinged, has no ability to really control his behavior, his mouth, and his antics?
你想让这种人代表你吗？你想让你的家族声誉被这个完全失控、无法控制自己的行为、嘴巴和滑稽动作的人弄脏吗？
So when Vaillancourt made his accusation, Buckley's friends dismissed the whole thing as an act of revenge. But the cops didn't see it that way. They searched for Buckley's old computer. They questioned more than a dozen people, many of whom Vaillancourt said would corroborate his claims.
所以当瓦兰考特提出指控时，巴克利的朋友们把整件事视为报复行为。但警察不这么看。他们搜查了巴克利的旧电脑。他们盘问了十几个人，其中许多是瓦兰考特说会佐证他主张的人。
And Vaillancourt kept on. He wanted to take a lie detector test, on TV if necessary. He made up a set of polygraph questions, complete with his answers. One of which was, "Did you and Mr. Buckley ever have a sexual relationship. Answer: No." And handed it around. He offered to be hypnotized, to take phenobarbital.
瓦兰考特继续纠缠。他想接受测谎仪测试，必要的话上电视。他编了一套测谎问题，连同他的答案。其中之一是，“你和巴克利先生有过性关系吗？答案：没有。”并四处分发。他主动要求被催眠，服用苯巴比妥。
When I asked him about the various theories people have for why he'd written his letter, Vaillancourt said his reason was simply to tell the truth. There was no jealousy, no vendetta.
当我问他人们对写信理由的各种猜测时，瓦兰考特说他的理由很简单，就是为了说实话。没有嫉妒，没有报复。
Wipe that out of your mind. There are three people I really hate in the world. Ray Buckley is not one of them. In fact, I admire Ray Buckley for being a good vegetarian, and for doing a lot of good things. So that is just hogwash. Peter Burling is one of the people I hate most in the world, and he's the one that developed that hogwash.
把那个念头从你的脑子里抹掉。世界上我有三个真正恨的人。雷·巴克利不是其中之一。事实上，我钦佩雷·巴克利作为一个好的素食主义者，做了很多好事。所以那是胡说八道。彼得·伯林是我世界上最恨的人之一，正是他编造了那些胡说八道。
Because what he'll say is you have professional jealousy.
因为他会说你有职业嫉妒心。
I've just explained to you, I have no professional jealousy. I have no desire to move up in the political ranks. I have a desire to promote my philosophy of government, get out of my back, out of my bed and out of my wallet.
我刚刚向你解释过了，我没有职业嫉妒心。我没有在政治等级制度中往上爬的欲望。我只有推广我的政府理念的愿望，离我远点，别插手我的床和钱包。
Weeks passed. And then a second set of charges came out against Buckley. This time, an unnamed former party staffer, calling himself a concerned Democrat, said Buckley was quote "Vulgar, disgraceful and indecent in the workplace." The person said his daily behavior included quote, "Sexually harassing male staffers, and blacklisting staffers that were not receptive to his sexual remarks or advances."
几周过去了。然后第二组指控出现在巴克利身上。这一次，一个匿名的前党工，自称是一个担心的民主党人，说巴克利在职场中“粗俗、丢脸且下流”。那个人说他的日常行为包括“性骚扰男性职员，并将那些对他性言论或追求不感冒的职员列入黑名单。”
Buckley was floored. He prides himself on getting young people interested in politics, the way he was. And he's got many proteges as proof. But Buckley can be really raunchy. He's quick to make a dick joke. And so it's easy to see how he could offend someone.
巴克利惊呆了。他以像他一样让年轻人对政治感兴趣而自豪。他有很多门徒作为证明。但巴克利确实可能真的很下流。他很容易开个生殖器玩笑。所以很容易看出他怎么会冒犯别人。
The Senate Democrats hired a lawyer to investigate, and Buckley was cleared of any wrongdoing. But still, it had made the papers, and the piling on was just exhausting.
参议院民主党雇了一名律师进行调查，巴克利被证明没有任何不当行为。但这一切还是上了报纸，这种堆叠起来的攻击真是让人精疲力竭。
Part of you is like, I don't want to talk about this anymore. I just want to get my life back. Then you realize that, wow, every time you've ever read of something even remotely similar to this happening to someone, you thought you understood what they were going through. And, oh boy, you do not. And you do not.
你的一部分会觉得，我不想再谈论这个了。我只想找回我的生活。然后你意识到，哇，每次当你读到类似的事情发生在别人身上时，你以为你理解他们正在经历什么。噢，男孩，你根本不理解。你完全不理解。
What was the most surprising part, just talk about that. What was the thing you hadn't anticipated or couldn't have imagined?
最令人惊讶的部分是什么，谈谈那个。什么是你没预料到或无法想象的？
The feeling that you're not in control of your life. That was probably the most difficult thing through the whole ordeal is that I wasn't in charge of my life. And as someone who, starting as a very small child, seemed to think that they were, at least, in control of me. That I was at the mercy of how people thought of me. I was at the mercy-- although, my entire life, obviously, was based on other people voting for me for either a party office or for an elective office and so my entire life has been at the mercy of other people and what they thought of me. But this was at a different level.
那种你无法掌控自己生活的感觉。这可能是整个磨难中最困难的事情，我无法掌控我的生活。而作为一个人，从很小的时候起，似乎就认为他们至少能掌控我。我受制于人们对我的看法。我受制于……虽然我的一生显然建立在别人为我投票，无论是党内职务还是民选职务，所以我的一生都受制于别人以及他们的看法。但这在另一个层面上。
Buckley became unsure. Not just about whether to throw out his trash, but unsure in the most basic way.
巴克利变得不确定了。不仅仅是关于是否要扔掉垃圾，而是在最基本的方式上变得不确定。
You just run through everything. It's like, was this a good choice for your life? What was this all about? Why did I move in that house? Why did I befriend that person that I knew was a different kind of person from day one? You know, why did my ego lead me to believe that I was going to fix this broken person?
你只是把一切都过了一遍。就像，这是你人生的一个好选择吗？这一切都是为了什么？为什么我搬进了那间房子？为什么我结交了那个我从第一天起就知道是不同类型的人？你知道，为什么我的自我会导致我认为我可以修复这个破碎的人？
Good afternoon. My name is Kelly Ayotte, the Attorney General for the state. I have with me the police chief from the City of Manchester, John Jaskolka.
下午好。我是州总检察长凯利·阿约特（Kelly Ayotte）。我和曼彻斯特市警察局长约翰·杰斯科尔卡（John Jaskolka）在一起。
And then, after more than two months, the Attorney General called a press conference.
然后，两个多月后，总检察长召开了新闻发布会。
We are here today to report that our investigation revealed absolutely no evidence that Raymond Buckley possessed child pornography. Therefore, we will not be bringing any criminal charges against Mr. Raymond Buckley.
我们今天在这里报告，我们的调查显示绝对没有任何证据表明雷蒙德·巴克利拥有儿童色情内容。因此，我们不会对雷蒙德·巴克利先生提出任何刑事指控。
And with those two sentences, it was over. The AG went on to say that no one they interviewed could corroborate anything Vaillancourt had said. No one had come forward with any evidence whatsoever. And that Vaillancourt himself couldn't describe seeing anything that constituted child pornography under New Hampshire statute. And that he had admitted to police that he had exaggerated in his letter to the governor.
随着那两句话，一切都结束了。总检察长接着说，他们采访的任何人都无法佐证瓦兰考特所说的一切。没有任何人提供任何证据。而且瓦兰考特本人也无法描述出任何构成新罕布什尔州法令下儿童色情内容的东西。他向警方承认他在给州长的信中夸大了。
And then someone asked whether Vaillancourt had essentially made all this up. It is clear that if she could have, the Attorney General would have said yes.
然后有人问瓦兰考特是否基本上完全捏造了这一切。很清楚，如果她能的话，总检察长会说“是的”。
I can tell you that we seriously considered bringing charges against Mr. Vaillancourt. However, the statute requires that we prove that someone knowingly made a false report to law enforcement. And so, therefore, that would be a difficult hurdle for us to initially overcome.
我可以告诉你，我们认真考虑过对瓦兰考特先生提出指控。然而，法令要求我们证明某人故意向执法部门做虚假报告。因此，这对我们来说最初是一个难以克服的障碍。
Vaillancourt was there in the crowd. Wearing a parka that belonged to Buckley's father, by the way, and videotaping the whole thing. He even asked a couple of questions. And the AG and the cops are answering, using his name in the third person like they don't recognize him, which maybe they don't. In any case, he stages a press conference immediately afterwards.
瓦兰考特就在人群中。顺便说一句，穿着巴克利父亲的外套，并录下了整个过程。他甚至问了几个问题。总检察长和警察在回答时，用第三人称称呼他的名字，好像不认识他，也许他们真的不认识。无论如何，他随后立即举行了新闻发布会。
I guess it's always good to quote those Dixie Chicks. "Not ready to make nice, I'm not ready to back down." Absolutely everything I wrote in the letter to Governor Lynch is correct. I have to say, I am so saddened in a sense today, because this investigation takes me back to when Mark Fuhrman found one glove behind Kato Kaelin's house and Detective Vannatter was running around Los Angeles, 30 miles with a vial of blood. Not since then has an investigation been so botched as this one.
我想引用“南方小鸡”乐队的话总是好的。“没准备好示好，我没准备好退缩。”我在给林奇州长的信中所写的一切绝对是正确的。我不得不说，今天在某种意义上我感到非常难过，因为这次调查让我想起了马克·福尔曼在凯托·凯林家后面发现一只手套，范纳特侦探在洛杉矶跑了30英里带那一小瓶血的时候。自那以后，没有一次调查像这次这样被搞砸了。
Vaillancourt said he was sure there was a cover-up, which he still believes. He said people had known about Buckley for years, and he couldn't understand why the cops gave up so easily. Then someone asked whether he was worried about what would happen to him now, about whether his reputation was ruined.
瓦兰考特说他确信有掩盖行为，他仍然相信。他说人们多年来一直了解巴克利，他不明白为什么警察放弃得这么快。然后有人问他是否担心现在会发生在他身上，他的名声是否会毁了。
I have only been happier three times in my life. Two other times. Once, my senior year in college, I was extremely happy. Good times. When I fell in love I was extremely happy. And now. I think it's like a giant cloud has been lifted from my soul. And I feel very happy and at peace with myself, more than I have ever done.
我一生中只有三次更快乐。另外两次。一次，我大学四年级的时候，我非常快乐。美好的时光。当我坠入爱河时我非常快乐。就是现在。我觉得就像有一朵巨大的云从我的灵魂中升起。我感到非常快乐，内心平静，比我以往任何时候都更加平静。
His only regret, he said, was that he hadn't come forward sooner. But it was like if your sister's doing heroin, he said, you should turn her in, but you just can't. She's your sister.
他说，他唯一的遗憾是没能早点站出来。但这就像如果你妹妹在吸海洛因，他说，你应该把她交出去，但你就是做不到。她是你的妹妹。
Buckley had been exonerated in the strongest way possible. And within days, he was back on top, doing what New Hampshire politicians do, attending events with presidential candidates. In this case, another scandal survivor, Hillary Clinton.
巴克利以最强有力的方式洗清了嫌疑。几天之内，他又回到了顶峰，做着新罕布什尔州政客们做的事，参加总统候选人的活动。在这种情况下，是另一位丑闻幸存者，希拉里·克林顿。
And Raymond Buckley, an early congratulations. You have-- and I have a bit of an idea what it's been like-- you have gone through this with grace and courage. Congratulations.
雷蒙德·巴克利，提前祝贺你。你已经……我也稍微知道那是什么样的体验……你带着优雅和勇气经历了这一切。祝贺你。
Hey, Rob. It's Ray Buckley, how are you?
嘿，罗布。我是雷·巴克利，你好吗？
How are you?
你好吗？
Good, good. Hey, obviously, I'm calling through the list for the state chair's race and calling to re-solicit your support, and hoping that you'd consider casting your ballot for me on the 24th?
好，好。嘿，显然，我正在拨打州主席竞选的名单，打电话重新争取你的支持，希望你能考虑在24号投我一票？
Ray's calling his former supporters. This one jokes, "You mean I can't abstain?"
雷在打电话给他的前支持者。这位开玩笑说，“你的意思是我不能弃权吗？”
You mean I can't abstain?
你的意思是我不能弃权吗？
No. [LAUGHING]
不。[大笑]
Yes, of course you have--
是的，当然你有——
I still have to ask, Rob.
我还是得问问，罗布。
Buckley was back in the race. The governor endorsed him again. I met with Buckley at the headquarters of the Manchester Democrats, eight days before the election. Buckley was working his way down a list of 196 names in tiny print.
巴克利回到了竞选中。州长再次支持了他。在选举前八天，我在曼彻斯特民主党总部会见了巴克利。巴克利正在一份印着小字的196人名单上一个接一个地打。
Let me make another call. I'm in the zone here. Hi, Jerry. It's Ray Buckley, how are you?
让我再打一个电话。我进入状态了。嗨，杰瑞。我是雷·巴克利，你好吗？
I'm fine, Ray, how are you?
我很好，雷，你呢？
I'm terrific now. [LAUGHING]
我现在好极了。[大笑]
It was going well. But while I was sitting there in his office, Buckley's cellphone started going nuts, buzzing every minute or two. He'd glance at it, and then keep talking. Until a call came from the current chair of the party, Kathy Sullivan. He spoke to her for a second, and then asked me to leave the room. And while I was standing outside his closed door, a local reporter called me and tipped me off about what was happening.
进行得很顺利。但当我坐在他的办公室里时，巴克利的手机开始疯狂响动，每分钟左右嗡嗡作响。他会瞥一眼，然后继续说话。直到党主席凯西·沙利文打来电话。他和她说了几秒钟，然后让我离开房间。当我站在他紧闭的门外时，一名当地记者给我打电话，向我透露了正在发生的事情。
Paul Hodes, the newly elected congressman, one of the state's top Democrats, had just issued a press release saying he was withdrawing his support for Buckley's candidacy because he'd seen a video of Buckley posted on YouTube. Hodes also said he thought the proper authorities should look into the matter. Suddenly, Buckley's candidacy was in jeopardy all over again.
新当选的国会议员保罗·霍兹（Paul Hodes），该州最高级别的民主党人之一，刚刚发表了一份新闻稿，称他撤回对巴克利竞选的支持，因为他看到了Youtube上发布的巴克利的视频。霍兹还表示，他认为有关当局应该调查此事。突然间，巴克利的竞选再次岌岌可危。
The YouTube thing had been posted the day before. Vaillancourt didn't post it himself, but he gave another Manchester Republican some old home movies for it. It showed Buckley in his 20s and 30s behaving not badly exactly, but embarrassingly. Doing things maybe a gay frat boy would do, and saying things you might say if you were on vacation with your friends, or playing a board game late at night. Which he was.
YouTube的事情是前一天发布的。瓦兰考特本人没有发布它，但他给了另一个曼彻斯特共和党人一些旧的家庭录像用于发布。录像显示巴克利在20多岁和30多岁时表现得并不算坏，但很尴尬。做着也许同性恋兄弟会成员会做的事，说着如果你和朋友度假或深夜玩棋盘游戏时可能会说的话。他确实在玩。
Would you like me to [BLEEP] you hard?
你想让我[哔——]你硬吗？
About this trip to the Hague.
关于这次去海牙的旅行。
Hitler should have bombed it.
希特勒早该炸了它。
This is from Vaillancourt's old home movies. And what's striking is how intimate they are. Even though the content is awful. He and Buckley were such close friends when he shot these movies.
这是来自瓦兰考特的旧家庭录像。引人注目的是它们是多么私密。即使内容很糟糕。他拍摄这些电影时，他和巴克利是如此亲密的朋友。
Put little clips on them and pull you down the [BLEEP] street right by your little nipples.
把小夹子夹在上面，把你拉到[哔——]街上，就在你那点小乳头上。
In another part of the video, a narrator points out that Buckley has a MySpace page that's just a few clicks away from gay teenagers. When I came back into the room, Buckley was trying to call his staff members back to work. He needed to send out an urgent email to party members to try to neutralize Hodes' statement. It was a Friday night, and there was a blizzard.
在视频的另一部分，旁白指出巴克利有一个MySpace页面，距离同性恋青少年只有几次点击的距离。当我回到房间时，巴克利正试图让他的员工回到工作岗位。他需要给党内成员发送紧急电子邮件，试图抵消霍兹的声明。那是周五晚上，而且有暴风雪。
Yeah. Hey, can you help me try to track down Michael so he can get back here? I can't hear you, Donna. His car probably isn't going to drive very well in this snow, but I need to send out an email. I'm at the city Dems office.
对。嘿，你能帮我查查迈克尔在哪吗，这样他能回来？我听不见你说话，唐娜。他的车在这雪里可能开得不太好，但我需要发送一封电子邮件。我在市民主党办公室。
I had asked Buckley about the YouTube clip the day before, when it was posted, and he laughed it off, saying the worst thing about it was that he realized how much he'd aged. The newspapers didn't seem interested either, and they didn't bother writing about it. Now Hodes had just made it a story, by saying he's withdrawing his support for Buckley because of it. And Buckley had to fight back.
前一天视频发布时，我问过巴克利关于那个YouTube剪辑的事，他大笑着否定了，说最糟糕的是他意识到自己变老了多少。报纸似乎也没兴趣，他们也没费心写报道。现在霍兹刚刚通过说因为这件事撤回对巴克利的支持，把它变成了一个新闻。巴克利不得不反击。
I dropped out once, I'm not doing it again.
我退出过一次，我不会再退出了。
Two staffers came in and went straight to their desks, as if they already knew what to do. Buckley sat down at a laptop. At this moment, he's fighting for his career. For his life's work, really. And what that entails, couldn't be more annoyingly small. He's trying to log on to YouTube and extract a six-minute video from cyberspace.
两个员工进来，直接走向他们的办公桌，好像他们已经知道该怎么做。巴克利坐在笔记本电脑前。在这一刻，他正在为自己的职业生涯而战。真的，为了他一生的事业。而这所涉及的事情，再也没有比这更烦人的小事了。他正试图登录YouTube并从网络空间提取一段六分钟的视频。
Don't touch. Because this is-- how do you even type on this thing?
别碰。因为这……你怎么在这个东西上打字？
2006.
2006。
No, it's my birthday. I was not born in 2006, Michael.
不，那是我的生日。我不是2006年出生的，迈克尔。
I was kidding, sir.
我是在开玩笑，先生。
Oh.
噢。
No one's saying much. They all seem utterly focused and purposeful, like a special ops team. Reporters are calling and Buckley is not picking up. And friends, a couple of whom are lawyers, are calling to give advice. It occurs to me that Buckley's probably had to do this dozens of times for other candidates. Politics is all about tearing down reputations and building them back up. So of course he knows what to do for his own crisis.
没人说话。他们看起来都非常专注和有目的，就像一支特种作战小组。记者们在打电话，巴克利没接。朋友们，其中几个是律师，打电话来提供建议。我想到巴克利可能已经为其他候选人做过几十次这种事了。政治就是关于摧毁名声并重新建立它们。所以他当然知道如何应对自己的危机。
They find out they can't shut down the video, but they can complain about it online. So their next strategy is to get their friends to become YouTube members, so they can flag the video as offensive.
他们发现无法关闭视频，但他们可以在网上投诉。所以他们的下一个策略是让朋友成为YouTube成员，这样他们就可以把视频标记为冒犯性的。
You know, Chris is at home. Obviously, Donna's at home. Call Judy. Just have them start calling people.
你知道，克里斯在家。显然，唐娜在家。打电话给朱迪。让他们开始联系人。
After about 40 minutes, they give up on Youtube, and concentrate instead on the email they're writing to committee members. Michael is on the phone with an adviser, and they decide on what the message should be. That at the time these movies were filmed, Buckley was young and immature. Michael suggests they fib about his age, and say the video was shot when Buckley was in his 20s. Buckley doesn't take his advice. He sidesteps how old he was and instead concentrates on the bigger question, who should they blame for the attack?
大约40分钟后，他们放弃了YouTube，转而集中精力写给委员会成员的邮件。迈克尔正在和一位顾问通话，他们决定了信息应该是什么内容。在那次电影拍摄时，巴克利还年轻且不成熟。迈克尔建议他们在年龄上撒谎，说视频是巴克利20多岁时拍摄的。巴克利没接受他的建议。他回避了年龄问题，转而集中讨论更大的问题，谁应该为这次攻击负责？
Party chairwoman Kathy Sullivan is on the phone, and she proposes blaming the Republican party as a whole. But Buckley isn't so sure.
党主席凯西·沙利文在电话上，她提议责备整个共和党。但巴克利不太确定。
Well, think about it. Because if it's clearly pinpointed, it's just the two of them operating on their own, as these two rogue, disgraced individuals. I guess I don't want to make this entirely about me against the Republican party.
嗯，考虑一下。因为如果明确指出，这只是他们两个人自己在操作，作为这两个流氓、丢脸的个人。我想我不想让这完全变成我和共和党之间的对抗。
You sure about that?
你确定吗？
That night the YouTube video had only been seen 365 times. Despite everything Buckley's people did, the thing stayed in the news for days. And by the end of the week, it had been seen 7,000 more times.
那天晚上YouTube视频只被观看了365次。尽管巴克利的人做了所有尝试，这件事还是在新闻中停留了几天。到周末结束时，它已经被观看了7000多次。
If all of you members of the state committee could please take your seats.
如果各位州委员会成员能请就座。
Finally, the state party had its meeting, where they would elect the new chairman.
最终，州党召开了会议，他们将在会上选举新主席。
Oh, Martha's writing a check. Then we won't have her take her seat.
噢，玛莎正在写支票。那我们就不让她就座了。
This was the moment Buckley had been fighting for three months. The moment that would decide whether he'd get his dream job. Whether he'd really survived. There was a little skirmish when congressman Paul Hodes, the guy who had started the Youtube flap, gave his speech. But mostly it was pretty civil. Eventually Kathy Sullivan took the mic.
这就是巴克利三个月来一直战斗的时刻。决定他是否能得到梦想工作的时刻。他是否真的活下来了。当YouTube风波发起者保罗·霍兹国会议员发表演讲时，有一点小冲突。但大多很文明。最终凯西·沙利文拿起了麦克风。
I have the results. Our new chairman, with a vote of 109, is Raymond Buckley.
我有结果了。我们的新主席，以109票当选，是雷蒙德·巴克利。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
After all the cheering, reporters mobbed Buckley, who talked about how, as the new chairman, he wanted to improve civility in political life in New Hampshire.
欢呼之后，记者们围住了巴克利，他谈到作为新主席，他想改善新罕布什尔州政治生活中的文明。
After the three months that I've just lived through, it's really my mission now. There's no way that you could've survived the few months that I did without coming out a changed person.
在我刚刚经历过三个月之后，这真的是我现在使命。没有改变，你就不可能度过那几个月。
Throughout this whole thing, people kept talking about the politics of personal destruction, and how shocked they were that these tactics had come to New Hampshire. But in a presidential primary year especially, it's hard to be optimistic that people will suddenly be nicer to each other.
在整个过程中，人们一直在谈论人身破坏政治，以及他们对这些策略来到新罕布什尔州感到多么震惊。但在总统初选年尤其如此，很难乐观地认为人们会突然对彼此更好。
The real change to come out of all this public, political drama, will probably end up being private and personal. Because even though his career might have survived, Buckley is changed. He told me he no longer trusts people the way he used to. He no longer wants to make new friends. He polices himself all the time, making sure he doesn't say anything that someone else might find offensive.
从所有这些公共政治戏剧中产生的真正改变，最终很可能是私人和个人的。因为即使他的事业可能幸存下来了，巴克利也变了。他告诉我他不再像过去那样信任别人。他不再想交新朋友。他一直监督自己，确保自己不说任何别人可能觉得冒犯的话。
The other day at lunch, a staff person used extreme language to reference a person. And I just quickly picked up what was left of my lunch and I said, "I have to leave the room, because you said that word. I have to leave."
前几天午餐时，一名员工使用极端语言来指代一个人。我很快收拾好午餐剩下的东西说，“我得离开房间，因为你说了那个词。我得走。”
Whereas before you would have laughed or just--
而以前你会笑，或者只是……
I wouldn't pay attention, I wouldn't be listening. Now I listen to everything that's going on around me, to make sure that nobody can misinterpret anything that anyone is saying near me that was inappropriate.
我不会注意，我不会听。现在我倾听周围发生的一切，以确保没有人可以曲解任何在他附近说的任何不恰当的话。
Because the attorney general's report was so emphatic about clearing him, and because the report was such big news, his reputation's about as good as he could hope for. Some people even said he came out looking stronger for all this.
因为总检察长的报告对洗清他的嫌疑非常强调，而且报告是如此大的新闻，他的名声比他希望的要好。有些人甚至说他因为这一切看起来更坚强了。
But Buckley thinks he's permanently changed. That he's not sure he'll ever really feel in control of his life again.
但巴克利认为他永久改变了。他不确定是否能真正再次掌控自己的生活。
Sarah Koenig is a producer of our show.
莎拉·科尼格是我们节目的制片人。
Coming up, what if you have a terrible reputation, and then you figure out that it is absolutely correct. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如果你有名声很臭，然后你发现它是完全正确的怎么办。一会儿就来，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring your a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show "My Reputation." We've arrived at act two of our show, act two. The Hole Truth.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，带来各种不同类型的关于那个主题的故事。今天的节目“我的名声”。我们到达了我们节目的第二幕，第二幕。“真相大白”。
I think most of us would rather not think about our reputations tpp much, you know? What's the point? What's it going to do for you? But in this next story one man, one brave man, faces his reputation. He sets out to learn, once and for all, what people really think of him. This brave man's name is Gabe Delahaye.
我想我们大多数人更愿意不太多想我们的名声，你知道吗？有什么意义？它会为你做什么？但在下一个故事中，一个人，一个勇敢的人，面对他的名声。他出发去了解，一劳永逸地，人们对他真正的想法。这个勇敢的人名叫盖布·德拉海（Gabe Delahaye）。
A warning to listeners that a word shows up in this story. A word that we beep.
提醒听众，这个故事中会出现一个词。我们消音的一个词。
I'm well aware that I have a certain reputation. My roommate, Andrew, who went to high school with me and knows me better than almost anyone, who is one of the most thoughtful and considerate people I know, puts it best.
我很清楚我有一个特定的名声。我的室友安德鲁（Andrew），跟我上高中，比任何人更了解我，是我认识的最深思熟虑和体贴的人之一，他总结得最好。
This is actually really hard to say to somebody's face, it turns out. I mean everyone-- I don't know. Sorry, I am actually trying to figure out the best way to do this. I don't know, everyone just thinks you're an ass[BLEEP].
这实际上很难当面说，事实证明。我是说每个人……我不知道。对不起，我实际上正在尝试找出最好的方式来做这个。我不知道，每个人都认为你是混蛋[哔——]。
I mean, it's true that I make fun of people all the time. But with my friends, at least, it comes from a good place. Like that time that Danielle asked me at the bar if I'd seen that episode of 90210 and I shouted "No," before she could even tell me which one. And then I laughed in her face. And, OK, I'd just met her that night. So Lindsey turned to me and said that she wanted me to teach her how to be such an ass[BLEEP]. And I told her it couldn't be taught. But we were all just joking around, right?
我是说，确实我总是取笑别人。但至少在我的朋友们那里，它来自一个好地方。就像那次丹妮尔（Danielle）在酒吧问我是否看过那集《飞越比弗利》时，我还没等她告诉我哪一集就大喊“没有”。然后我对着她的脸大笑。噢，好吧，我那天晚上才刚见到她。所以琳赛（Lindsey）转过身对我说，她想让我教她如何成为一个混蛋[哔——]。我告诉她这没法教。但我们都在开玩笑，对吧？
That's how I saw it. And I assumed my friends saw it that way, too. I mean, Andrew calls me an ass[BLEEP] all the time. He warns people about me, right in front of me. But he wouldn't still be my friend if it wasn't kind of a joke. It's just this role that I've been assigned in our group of friends, a role I'm more than happy to play.
那就是我看它的方式。我以为我的朋友们也那样看。我是说，安德鲁一直叫我混蛋[哔——]。他就在我面前警告别人关于我，对吧？但他不会仍然是我的朋友如果它不是一种玩笑。这就是我在我们的朋友群中被分配到的角色，一个我非常乐意扮演的角色。
So I sat Andrew down, to make sure he felt the same way. That I'm a quote, unquote, ass[BLEEP]. But I'm not really an ass[BLEEP]. And, right away, he brings up the emails that led to this very conversation. I had written to ask him if he could be home at 8:00, to talk on tape.
所以我让安德鲁坐下来，确定他有同样的感受。我是个所谓的混蛋[哔——]。但我不是真正的混蛋[哔——]。而且，立刻，他提起了导致这次对话的邮件。我写信问他是否可以在8点回家，在磁带上谈谈。
And at this point, I say, "All right, that sounds pretty good. Make sure to tell craft services I am ovo-lacto," which is maybe not the funniest joke but, you know. And you reply, I think out of nowhere, "Sure. How do you take your coffee? Like your women, right? So that's rarely." And then you write, "Zing." I thought the whole thing was a little unnecessary.
而在这一点上，我说，“好吧，那听起来不错。一定要告诉制作服务我是蛋奶素，”这也许不是最有趣的笑话，你知道。而你回复，我想完全出乎意料，“当然。你咖啡怎么喝？像你的女人一样吗？很少。”然后你写，“叮。”我觉得整件事有点没必要。
But you don't, uh, drink a lot of coffee. Right?
但你并不，呃，喝很多咖啡。对吧？
Yeah, that's true.
是的，那是真的。
Have you ever seen me be nice to people?
你见过我对人友善吗？
Yeah. I can't think of any examples, but I'm sure you have. I'm sure you have. Like if you weren't paying attention or something. You've probably gotten up on the subway for somebody or something, right? Maybe not.
是的。我想不出任何例子，但我确定你有。我确定你有。就像如果你没注意或什么。你可能在地铁上给别人让座或什么，对吧？也许没有。
Why are you still friends with me?
为什么你还是我的朋友？
I don't know. Inertia?
我不知道。惯性？
Inertia. Did you hear him say that he was only friends with me out of inertia? And I'm the ass[BLEEP]?
惯性。你听到他说他和我做朋友只是出于惯性吗？我是混蛋[哔——]？
So we're sitting there talking about this stuff, and our friend Travis, who lives in the neighborhood, showed up. And once the two of them could compare notes, something changed. For one, they didn't just think I was an ass[BLEEP] because of a well meaning joke taken too far. It was more than that. Like the time Travis wouldn't take off his stupid bicycle helmet.
所以我们坐在那里谈论这些东西，我们的朋友特拉维斯（Travis），住在附近，出现了。一旦他们俩能对比笔记，事情就变了。一方面，他们不只是认为我是混蛋[哔——]，因为一个善意的玩笑走得太远了。它不仅仅是那样。就像那次特拉维斯不肯脱下他愚蠢的自行车头盔。
I think I was carrying something else. Like, it was just easier to just put the helmet on my head, even though I wasn't on my bike. But for some reason, that prompted you to keeps hitting me on my head. Which, you know, it was kind of funny the first time but it actually kind of hurt. And I was, like, stop doing that. So I was telling someone else about it. Like, can you believe what a jerk this guy is? Like, why is he your friend? It's like, well.
我想我正带着别的东西。就像，把头盔戴在头上更容易，即使我没骑车。但由于某种原因，那促使你不停地敲我的头。这，你知道，第一次还有点好笑，但它实际上有点痛。我当时想，停止那样做。所以我告诉了别人。就像，你能相信这人是多大的混蛋吗？为什么他是你的朋友？就像，嗯。
I was telling you to take the helmet off, though.
不过我在让你把头盔拿下来。
Yeah, but that's not a good way to tell someone to take the helmet off.
是的，但那不是让人把头盔拿下来的好方法。
He was right, that was kind of bad. It was like in elementary school when someone would grab your hand and start hitting you in the face with your own hand, and ask you why you were hitting yourself. Who does that? Apparently, I do.
他是对的，那有点糟糕。这就像在小学，有人会抓住你的手开始用你自己的手打你的脸，问你为什么打你自己。谁会那样做？显然，我做了。
And the more they talked, the more obvious it became that their feelings about my behavior went much deeper than just thinking I can be an ass[BLEEP]. They admitted that lots of times they'll email each other all day long without including me, because they figure I'll just make fun of them. And at that moment, in the middle of a question, I had one of those realizations in which you see something you thought you understood in a totally new light.
他们谈论得越多，他们对我的行为的感觉远远超过仅仅认为我可以是一个混蛋[哔——]变得越明显。他们承认很多时候他们会整天给彼此发邮件而不包括我，因为他们觉得我只会取笑他们。而在那一刻，在问题中间，我有了一次那种领悟，你以全新的视角看待你以为你理解的东西。
I find that there have been countless situations where I'll call you, and you're out with everybody. And no one has called me. Now that could be because I'm an ass[BLEEP] and you guys don't want to hang out with me, I'm now realizing. Only now. But that's a very-- that's always been very hurtful to me.
我发现有无数次情况我会打电话给你，你和大家在一起。而没有人打给我。现在这可能是因为我是混蛋[哔——]，你们不想和我混在一起，我现在意识到了。只有现在。但这一个……那对我一直都很伤人。
It's hard to describe what this was like. The room actually seemed to shrink. Of course it wasn't that every single one of my friends forgot to invite me, repeatedly. Of course. And maybe it was the uncomfortable laughter, but they hardly noticed that my face was red, and I was drenched in sweat. I could imagine that an acquaintance, or somebody who had just met me, might feel this way about me. But these were two of my best friends and there were times when they would just rather avoid me altogether. Here's Travis.
很难描述这像什么。房间看起来实际上缩小了。当然并不是每一个我的朋友都忘了邀请我，反复地。当然。也许是不舒服的笑声，但他们几乎没注意到我的脸红了，我浑身是汗。我可以想象一个熟人，或一个刚见到我的人，可能会那样看待我。但这是我最好的两个朋友，有几次他们宁愿完全避开我。这是特拉维斯。
It kind of seems like you intentionally try and be the kind of aggressive guy who makes people uncomfortable, or whatever.
看起来你是有意尝试做那种让人们不舒服的激进家伙，或什么。
Andrew chimed in.
安德鲁附和道。
Yeah. I feel like you end up setting the threshold for what people's comfort level with your relationship is. The amount of aggression, or back and forth. And if they don't like it, it's often just, like, that's it.
是的。我觉得你最终设定了人们对你关系的舒适度的门槛。那种攻击性，或来来回回。如果他们不喜欢，它经常就只是，就这样。
I guess I just assumed we all have our flaws. Andrew is the kind of guy who argues everything, and I mean everything. Like the   word grill, which is popular slang for face. Andrew has maintained for years that it is slang for a rib cage, despite a thousand rap songs to the contrary. Or if Andrew's tired, and you're hanging out with him, he just talks about being tired the whole time. And it's like, dude, I get it. You're tired. Go take a nap.
我猜我只是假设我们都有缺陷。安德鲁是那种争论一切的人，我是说一切。就像“烧烤”这个词，是脸的流行俚语。安德鲁多年来坚持认为它是肋骨的俚语，尽管有成千上万的说唱歌曲反其道而行之。或者如果安德鲁累了，你和他混在一起，他整个时间都在谈论累。就像，伙计，我知道了。你累了。去小睡一下。
But that's my point. We're friends, so I accept all that about him. I don't warn people to avoid the word grill around Andrew. I don't tell them in advance that most of Travis' day-to-day conversation is a string of impenetrable one liner inside jokes that he would never bother explaining to someone who didn't understand them already. I accept these things about Andrew and Travis as part of the deal. Just like I expected them to accept that I can be an ass[BLEEP]. Which, actually, I guess they do. I just don't get to decide what that acceptance looks like.
但这就是我的观点。我们是朋友，所以我接受关于他的一切。我不警告人们在安德鲁面前避免使用烧烤这个词。我不会提前告诉他们，特拉维斯的大部分日常谈话是一串不可穿透的单线笑话，他永远不会费心向已经理解的人解释。我接受关于安德鲁和特拉维斯的这些东西作为交易的一部分。就像我希望他们接受我可以是一个混蛋[哔——]。这实际上，我猜他们确实做了。我只是没有决定那种接受看起来像什么。
We're friends. We're friends. But some of the time spent with you is not fun.
我们是朋友。我们是朋友。但和你在一起花掉的一些时间是不好玩的。
That's really well put. It's not about like or dislike. It's about just how you treat people, I guess.
那总结得真好。这关于喜不喜欢。这是关于你如何对待人，我猜。
When Travis left, it was pretty tense in our apartment. Andrew and I spent half an hour making small talk. Saying things like, "Dinner is a really great meal, you know? Like out of the three?" Just to ensure that our friendship hadn't suffered a mortal blow.
当特拉维斯离开时，我们的公寓里很紧张。安德鲁和我花半小时进行小谈话。说些话比如，“晚餐真是顿很棒的饭，你知道吗？就像这三顿中的？”只是为了确保我们的友谊没有遭受致命打击。
The next morning, I woke up with an emotional hangover. I had that anxiety where it feels like someone is sitting on your chest and I left early for work to avoid seeing Andrew again. I spent the whole day writing emails to people, asking them to remind me that I'm not an ass[BLEEP]. When I told them that I was confronting this reputation head on, the typical reaction was not reassure me, but just to tell me how brave I was for trying. "Oh," one of them wrote. "I don't think I could do what you're doing. That sounds really hard."
第二天早上，我醒来时带着情绪宿醉。我有那种焦虑，感觉有人坐在我的胸口上，我早早去上班，为了避免再次见到安德鲁。我花了一整天给人们写邮件，请他们提醒我我不是混蛋[哔——]。当我告诉他们我正面面对这个名声时，典型的反应不是安慰我，而只是告诉我为了尝试我有多勇敢。“噢，”其中一个人写道。“我想我做不到你正在做的事。那听起来真难。”
Over the next few weeks, I talked to friends and family to see if they felt the same way. And everyone, down to the last man, had something to say on the subject. My brother.
在接下来的几周里，我和朋友和家人交谈，看他们是否也有同样的感受。每个人，一直到最后一个人，都有关于这个话题要说。我的兄弟。
You know, it's embarrassing, of course. Sometimes you go a bit over the top.
你知道，这很尴尬，当然。有时你有点过头了。
My ex-girlfriend Kate.
我的前女友凯特（Kate）。
I think you, honestly, embrace it. I mean, do you like knowing that people say they don't like you?
我认为你，老实说，拥抱它。我是说，你喜欢知道人们说他们不喜欢你吗？
My friend Scott.
我的朋友斯科特（Scott）。
I didn't like you before I met you. And I had decided that I was not going to talk to you or give you the time of day. And I also tried to persuade other people to dislike you.
在见到你之前我不喜欢你。我决定我不会跟你说话或给你时间。而且我也试图说服别人不喜欢你。
Even my mom.
甚至我的妈妈。
Well, it used to bother me. Because I thought, wow, all this energy I put into this kid and he makes fun of me. Then I got OK with it. I think that's kind of where I'm at, I'm mostly OK with it.
嗯，它以前困扰我。因为我想，哇，我投入到这孩子身上的所有能量，他却取笑我。然后我对它没关系了。我认为这在某种程度上就是我在的地方，我大部分时间对它没关系。
It's easy to dismiss Andrew or Scott. But my mom? How do I dismiss my mom? By the time I talked to my friend Carey, who just decided, like, last Friday that she didn't hate me anymore, she asked me the next logical question.
忽略安德鲁或斯科特很容易。但我的妈妈？我怎么忽略我的妈妈？当我交谈到我的朋友凯莉（Carey）时，她只是决定，就像，上周五她不再恨我了，她问我下一个合乎逻辑的问题。
So what are you going to do? Are you going to change?
所以你打算做什么？你会改变吗？
Well. Uh.
嗯。呃。
It was in that pause right there, when I avoided answering, that I realized what I had done. I believe I'm the first person in history to have staged an intervention on himself.
就是在那停顿中，当我避免回答时，我意识到我做了什么。我相信我是历史上第一个对自己策划干预的人。
What started out as an attempt to force Andrew into admitting that I wasn't an ass[BLEEP] became a referendum on me as a person, with everyone agreeing that he was kind of right. And while I might not have thrown any furniture, or beaten my fist against the wall, crying out, "How could you all do this to me?" I did what a lot of people in interventions do. I looked my friends and family in the eye, apologized and then politely refused to go to rehab.
开始时试图强迫安德鲁承认我不是混蛋[哔——]，变成了一个关于我作为人的全民公决，每个人都同意他是对的。虽然我可能没有扔掉任何家具，或用拳头撞墙，大喊“你们怎么能都这样对我？”我做了很多在干预中人们做的事。我看着我朋友和家人的眼睛，道歉，然后礼貌地拒绝去康复中心。
Because, unpleasant as I discovered I can be, I just know in my heart that I'm not changing. And in response to Carey's question, which is the most obvious question to ask, what am I going to do? Why don't I change? Why don't I stop the teasing and the fake punching and the helmet slapping? I don't know. Inertia?
因为，虽然我发现我可能很令人不快，但我心里知道我不会改变。而对于凯莉的问题，这是最明显的问题，我打算做什么？为什么我不改变？为什么我不停止取笑和假打和拍头盔？我不知道。惯性？
Gabriel Delahaye, is an ass[BLEEP] living in New York.
盖布里埃尔·德拉海（Gabriel Delahaye），是生活在纽约的混蛋[哔——]。
Our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help for our show by Seth Lind and Tommy Andres. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Web help from Jorge Just and Xioa  Jao Yung.
我们的节目今天由莎拉·科尼格和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格，简·费尔特斯，丽莎·波拉克，阿丽莎·希普，和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们节目的制作帮助来自塞斯·林德和汤米·安德雷斯。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。网页帮助来自豪尔赫·贾斯特和萧兆阳。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, were you can get our free weekly podcast, see free clips from our television show, or listen to any of our old shows for that same price, free. www.thisamericanlife.org. We are also trying this experiment right now on vox.com, we have a place where you can talk about This American Life online with other people who listen to the show. vox.com.
我们的网站，在那里你可以得到我们免费的周播播客，看我们电视节目的免费片段，或以同样的价格听我们任何旧节目，免费。www.thisamericanlife.org。我们也在现在尝试这个实验在vox.com，我们有一个地方，你可以和听节目的其他人在线谈论《美国生活》。vox.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Torey Malatia, who really wishes we hadn't aired that story about him a couple weeks ago.
WBEZ管理监督我们节目的是我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他真心希望我们几周前没播出那个关于他的故事。
Yeah, no, I was like, "I told you guys that we shouldn't try to make this into a story. And now look. I'm a lesbian in Japan."
是的，没有，我当时就像，“我告诉过你们，我们不应该尝试把它写成专题。现在好了，我在日本成了同性恋。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带着《美国生活》的更多故事。